[تصفيق]
يوتيوب ميسي
المتوجين بكاس موسم الريال
يتقدمهم
سيرخيو راموس رجل معارك الاوروبيه الكبيره
مع ريال مدريد
بقيه النجوم في هذه الاثناء نيمار وميسي
والبقيه
الحضن والاحضان هنا والحضن الكبير لليوم
مع مناصب في هذه اللقطه
والتحيه لهذه الاجواء امامنا رجل في هذه
الصوره الاول على اليسار في هذه اللقطه
مشرف مشرف الغامدي
ما زال كبير
النجوم
دخل التاريخ الكره
كانت ممتعه ليله كانت ممتعه
لا اجواء ممتعه
وبطبيعه الحال
يستمر تتويج ابطال موسم الريال
بطوله دوري ابطال اوروبا في هذا الموسم
يستعدون من اجل ذلك بقوه
ضع وفره كل العناصر تؤهلهم للفوز
بالشامبيون
لحظات مهمه وجميله في سعد الملك فهد
الدولي وانتظار بعد ذلك كام رفع الكاس
القائد ماركينيوس اخر الاسماء في هذه
اللحظات يستعد ايضا
ان يلتقي مع زملاء في المنصه ويرفع الكاس
كاس موسم الريال الي يفوز فيها
على حسابي
نجوم النصر والهلال بعد مباراه كبيره
انتهت بخمسه اهداف مقابل اربعه معالي
المستشار تركي ال الشيخ راح يقدم الكاس
ل ماركينيوس موسم الريال
والبسي يستحق هذه الكاس مبروك ريف ياسين
مبروك
لمريس سان جيرمان
احتفاليه غير
عن نجوى خياليه
[موسيقى]
لا تنسى في كلب العاصمه الريال شكرا
بكل من جعلنا من الحلم واقع حقيقه نعيشه
واياكم وننتظر الكثير الايام القادمه
لجوميزى مع الكاس والفوز بهذه المباراه
الكبيره بعد ليله احتفاءه رائعه غايه
باضيف حكيمي راموس ميسي نيمار والفقير هذا
هو الاستاذ الرهيب اللي يستمر في استضافه
الاحداث الكبيره وهذه الاجواء انتهى كل
شيء سيداتي وسادتي في المباراه
في
استاد الملك فهد الدولي
شكرا للمتابعه الان عوده للزمير عزيز تركي
العجمه بعد فاصل القصير